[Music]
logo designers worked hard to make sure
that one picture can perfectly represent
a brand that you will recognize in less
than a second but if you saw what they
look like years ago it wouldn't have the
same effect just wait until you see what
Twitter's logo first looks like we have
to admit that it was a little disgusting
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 15 famous logos
that looked very different back then
McDonald's as soon as we see these
golden arches we immediately feel hungry
it is a symbol that we could easily
recognize no matter where we are in the
world and we have to admit that we are
all loving it but decades ago McDonald's
logo was not the kind of picture that
would easily stand out from 1948 to 1953
a black and white logo simply said
McDonald's famous hamburgers buy them by
the bag then in 1953 a new logo was
created as the fast-food restaurant
became a franchise and the name was
shortened to McDonald's you could see
speedy McDonald's first mascot in the
picture it was used until 1968 when it
was replaced by the mascot we all know
Ronald McDonald it's in 1961 that we
first got the chance to see the golden
arches the logo changed a little bit
over time until it became the one we all
know today it is probably now one of the
most famous logos in the world Lego this
logo might be really simple but it has
everything it takes to be fun the
vibrant colors surround letters and a
look that any child would easily
recognize but in 1934 Legos logo was
kind of boring it was simply the name of
the brand written in black the logo was
not used on toys yet so they didn't need
to get the attention of children by 1940
the company had a new logo for their
wooden toys and then a new one in the
50s for the plastic toys it's also at
that time that the logo started to look
like the one we know today the company
tried different kinds of fonts and
different colors until they found the
one that was the most popular the logo
that they created in the 70s was really
similar to the one we know today as they
simply used graphic tightening for a
better digital reproduction coca-cola as
soon as we see this logo on a bottle or
can we know that we are going to open
happiness but did you know that this
drink is 100
thirty years old Frank M Robinson is the
one who designed the logo he thought
that the two letters C looked good in
advertising and through the logo and
flowy handwriting everyone agreed that
it looked good and this is also the
reason why it is really similar to the
logo we know today but the designer went
a little crazy in 1890 when he created a
new logo with a lot of extra swirls it
was so unpopular that it lasted for only
a year before they went back to the
previous logo then all they needed was a
little more red to make sure that the
drink gets all the attention it deserves
Pepsi this time the soft drink went
through a lot more transformations over
the years just recently the company paid
1 million dollars to change their logo
and we're not sure that it was worth it
even though they claim that it has
something to do with the golden ratio
but if you look at the first logo from
1898 you'll see that a lot of things
have changed since company was created
it had all the extra twirls that didn't
work for coca-cola and we think that it
made the logo what kind of messy they
simplified it in the 1900s but it was
still really similar to the popular soft
drink it is not until the 40s that they
added the red white and blue to
represent the colors at the United
States then in the 60s they changed the
name Pepsi Cola or Pepsi only and
improved the look of the logo over the
years
Nike it is so easy to recognize this
athletic clothing brand that they don't
even need to add their name in the logo
anymore the Solow swoosh is all they
need for people all around the world to
know who they are and actually it has
always been a part of the design in 1971
it was behind the name of the brand
until they moved it under so it would be
easier to read the swoosh has the
ability to make a scene movement in a
simple picture it represents the wing of
the statue of the Greek goddess of
victory also names Nike it is surprising
to think that if designer Carolyn
Davidson was paid only $35 for the right
to use the logo in 1971 if she knew that
this brand would become so popular she
would have asked for more almost 20
years after it you still see this logo
on everyone's clothes at the gym Google
you probably use Google services every
day to search something read your emails
go on YouTube or simply surf the web it
became such an important part of our
lives that we even invented the verb
googling this is why you have already
seen the technology company changed its
logo many times on special occasions it
all started in 1997 during the
pre-launch when the logo looked a little
too childish but they quickly fixed it
in 1998 to make it simpler
there was also an exclamation mark for a
year but it didn't last long until they
got rid of it and now it is so easy to
recognize the colors and the letter G
that Google isn't shy to have fun with
their logo
the first doodles in the 2000s were
simple but always playful and the
company tried a lot of different things
over the years for occasions like
Valentine's Day the New Year's Day or
someone's birthday our favorite one is
probably the one in which we can play
pac-man what about you Instagram there
are millions of pictures on this app but
did you pay attention to the picture of
the app itself the logo was changed in
2016 to a sunset of colors to simplify
the Polaroid camera many people
complained and said that they wanted the
original logo back but little did they
know most of them didn't know what they
were talking about the original logo
before 2010 was actually a much more
realistic polaroid camera designed by
CEO Kevin Systrom himself but he thought
that it had nothing to do with the app
and asked for the help of the user
designer and photographer Cole rides
even if the logo was recently changed
Rhys loves it even more he says that he
likes minimalism the white shape of the
symbol and thinks that this new logo
will persist over time we have to get
used to it at first but we have to admit
that we now prefer the new one to Ikea
if you ever went to Ikea you have
probably seen this logo a lot just like
us
and that's not because we were
fascinated by it but because we kept
getting lost in this maze and kept
seeing the logo everywhere the logo is
much simpler than building any of the
furniture from this store it is the name
of the brand and capital letters on a
blue and yellow background but the first
logo looked more like something you
would see on a jar of strawberry jam the
logo changed a lot in the early 50s to
be simplified by 1953 then the designers
experimented with a lot of colors until
they found what would look best for the
brand in 1967 the logo had the shape
that we know but was in black and white
then in 1981 it was in red and white
not until 1992 that we saw the blue and
yellow logo that we all know today
Volkswagen many of us think of having
the chance to own that car maybe even a
vintage one but did you ever think of
what the logo used to look like at that
time we all recognize that stylish
letter W that we see today on a blue
background but the original logo used to
be really different before the war in
1937 to 1939 the logo looked much more
psychedelic with all these blinds it was
quickly modified during the war from
1939 to 1945 and then in 1945 it was
already really similar to the famous
logo that we can see today the company
experimented with different shades of
blue until the 2000s then for the new
millennium it received a 3d makeover in
2012 a shine was added to make the logo
stand out and it is still the one that
the company uses nowadays Internet
Explorer the Internet changed so quickly
that the logo we saw two decades earlier
already looks really kitsch
the Internet Explorer logo is now more
modern it's simplified look and the
light blue color but do you remember
what Microsoft Internet Explorer 1 looks
like in 1995 the resolution in this
picture is so low that it makes us feel
a little bit older and we're not sure
about the choice of dark blue and green
color either the icon stayed the same
for several years while the logo kept
changing for every new version this
modern world is moving fast
just like the company it's in 1996 that
we first saw the design letter e in the
logo and the letter was used on its own
since the 2000 the company kept
improving the logo every year and you
can probably see the final results on
your computer now shell with that name
the oil and gas company couldn't really
change their logo this is why you can
still see a red and yellow shell
nowadays when you're looking for a gas
station the name of the company shell
transport and trading company appeared
in 1891 as they dealt with antiques and
oriental seashells the first logo in
1901 with a mussel shell but it didn't
look so good this is why they quickly
changed it for a scallop shell in 1904
when the Royal Dutch petroleum company
merged with them they shortened the name
the design of the logo changed over the
years in line with trends and graphic
design it is in 1948 that we first saw a
logo that looks like the one we know
nowadays since that time the low
was improved to simplify it and give it
a more modern look Yamaha this logo is
probably the one that changed the most
over the years now the logo is really
simple it is the name of the brand and
capital letters and bright red with a
symbol on the left but in 1898 we
couldn't see anything similar in these
two logos it was an elaborate design of
a Chinese Phoenix holding a tuning fork
in its mouth as the company was known
for selling top quality organs at that
time after different designs with the
tuning forks alone the design
drastically changed with a piano in 1934
it didn't last long as we could see the
tuning forks alone again during the
following years it is only in 1967 that
we saw a logo similar to the one we see
nowadays there are now two different
logos a purple one for the Yamaha
Corporation and a red one for Yamaha
Motor the brand known for selling
motorcycles and even if you're on the
road you can still see the tuning forks
on the Left Apple
you probably have one of these bitten
apples right in front of you on your Mac
your iPhone or your iPad but did you
ever wonder what it looked like before
this brand was so popular the original
logo featured Isaac Newton under an
apple tree but they were looking for
something simpler
so they preferred a colorful bitten
apple instead the myth says that this is
an homage to Alan Turing a homosexual
who ended his life by biting into a
poison apple according to rob John off
the designer the only reason why the
Apple is bitten is to make sure that we
won't mistake it for a tomato then in
1998 when Steve Jobs returned to the
company they designed a monochrome logo
that they could put on all their
products without making it look childish
and you can probably see the result
right in front of you as you're watching
this video
Starbucks if you like to buy a coffee
every day you probably asked yourself
this question while you are waiting in
line is this woman in the picture you
will find the answer on the original
logo before 1987 on this logo you can
see a mermaid with her breasts exposed
and her legs spread but what does it
have to do with coffee it was a
representation of a twin tailed siren
from the 15th century she represented
the temptation men can't resist just
like you can't resist buying this
expensive coffee to make the logo more
family-friendly her breasts were covered
by her hair from 1987 to 1992 and
following this they also cropped the
picture so we couldn't see that she was
spreading her legs we thought that the
logo was weird when we first saw it but
it is just weirder now that we have seen
the original picture Twitter if you want
to tweet about a fun fact tell your
friends about this you probably see this
blue logo with the blue bird every day
but the original one is a little more
disgusting back in 2005 people were
looking for names for their new social
media platform they came up with names
like twitch and friend stalker but the
one they finally chose was Twitter
however the logo they designed was not
really good looking no a glass came up
with the idea and thought that it
inspired youthfulness we are really
happy to see that they changed their
minds and chose the Bluebird and said we
don't think that Twitter would have been
really popular with this strange green
design would you like to see any of
these brands using their original logos
to sell vintage products tell us what
would be your favorite one in the
comment section below and that's it for
15 famous logos that looked very
different back then
if you want to hear more about logos
don't forget to watch 15 hidden images
in logos you've never noticed thanks for
watching
[Music]